do you think we beat the japanese just
because i mean we're just bigger kids
because we
more protein raw fish raw fish can only
give you so much protein
yeah yeah you got big kids we cows yeah
we're big kids so you know
they want to fly their little [ __ ]
planes in there that they fit their
little bodies but they're too little
so what happened is we came in with the
big boys it's like yeah you shook up you
sunk a couple of our battleships
yeah but then we have to drop the
[ __ ] hammer on you unfortunately you
had to get nuked yeah
yeah a lot of fun
[Music]
this is all a character that's what it
is it's like you know what guy you want
to [ __ ]
here's the thing here's the listen
imperial 1941 japan here's the thing
if you're hearing it and it's not
counting you're hearing it here's
the issue here's the issue here's what
happened here's what here's what we said
we said
okay yeah you know what yeah you sunk a
few of our battleships but guess what
now your whole country's going in the
microwave
[Laughter]
you know i had a feeling that this might
be dangerous first
first episode back with you in the
states this close to fourth of july
i had a feeling that maybe pearl harbor
was a little bit too much of a dangerous
topic
yeah cause i don't know if you just
heard that if you did
because we're just spinning the wheel
with whatever isis wants to tackle
because at this point we're going donald
trump there's just too much
yeah we can't tackle the whole episode
chrissy yeah i'm just kidding yeah we're
doing a character piece
last one well we should calculate the
first part but
do we got to lose the last thing i don't
know i don't know anymore i mean it's
just sorry
that one was okay okay yeah but we lose
it first it's historically
accurate yeah yeah yeah it's just you
know unfortunately yeah we had to
yeah yeah can your country took a couple
of hot pockets but
look it was it's just what it was yeah
i'm sorry it's a bad thing that happened
to everybody
yeah i know it's horrible that civilians
had to suffer it is absolutely hard
that uh civilians had to uh had to
suffer there
but you did a trip you did wake up the
boys yeah i mean i don't know
what you're really thinking yeah look
there's a lot of conspiracy theorists
out there that say
blah blah blah listen the truth of the
situation is
they woke up the boys it was a
preemptive attack yeah uh they didn't
declare war on us
yeah a couple of thousand boys died it
was brutal they sunk some battleships
but most of them we repaired and got
them right back up and they were in
action the only one we lost was
arizona and listen we don't care about
him because john mccain was a senator
from arizona and he was mean to our
fuhrer donald trump yeah no obviously
we're just joking can i get away zhang
jing that was a complete religion
yeah we're just we're just that was a
character piece called i'm chrissy dave
yeah yeah yeah so um i do not support
donald trump
neither do i um i don't support anybody
yeah no
me neither neither from 2020. uh uh
shane yeah but um but yeah so world war
ii had been going on already for a
couple years in europe
and asia and so i think what the
thinking was is that
you know uh you know japan wanted to
take over more
territory yeah so i think in order to do
that they felt like
because they were getting closer and
closer to hawaii
they want they felt like you know what
we don't want to get too close and then
the us decides they want to you know
they don't like what we're doing because
they're basically [ __ ]
you know japan was brutal i mean yeah
germany gets all the press but japan was
being brutal there was a lot of war
crimes
rape of nan king and they were really
being like atrocious there was like a
lot of atrocities that were committed by
the
by the uh you know country of japan
during world war ii times
so i think that they felt that
you know what before the us finds out
what we're doing and wants to get
involved
and has the whole weight of their navy
and army at us let's try to
knock them out of the war before they
can even begin yeah well that was a big
mistake
well we had sanctions on them we had
sanctions but we in some ways we the
detention had been high for a while
right now and um
they the british had some outposts there
guam et cetera et cetera et cetera in
pearl harbor
in the eastern hemisphere yeah in the
eastern eastern hemisphere the british
had some alpha yeah
so they thought we were gonna they
wanted those outposts
they thought we were gonna defend those
ups we were trying to negotiate yeah we
wanted them
out of china they were already in china
we were trying to do these conditional
surrenders they kept trying to negotiate
and basically roosevelt at the time said
we don't negotiate with terrorists yeah
and that's just what happened i mean
that's just the way you can that's the
way you can
you you can really sum it up is they
were trying to negotiate
japan wanted certain things and
roosevelt just said no we want a full
withdrawal of china we don't negotiate
with terrorists
and it's what it is we may or may not
attack you it's what it is they wanted
japan
out of china they want japan a hundred
percent out of china and japan said no
okay
yeah yeah so we kept trying to negotiate
and actually i think the
the last negotiation they tried to do
actually happened while
their uh aircraft carriers had already
left yeah to go into the pacific ocean
yeah and and the leader
um the leader to attack us yeah and the
guy who's like idea
was hideki matsuya no not hideki next
year that guy played through yankees
um this guy uh yamamoto was this is
yeah he sounds like uh yeah one of my
stereos um
suzuki so yeah suzuki he he didn't want
to go to war
he did not want to go to war with the
u.s because he knew
that the full industrial might and will
of the americans
uh who you know because he he knew that
basically the americans were better he
knew that that the americans
that we they weren't going to beat us
because we had all the [ __ ]
industry in america we had the war
machine we just were choosing to stay
neutral
so he actually really didn't want to do
it but however we also had rock and roll
which kept us loose
we kept this very loose yeah when you
get on the battlefield and you're
listening to a little chuck barry keeps
you loose keeps you loose
even though he's pissing on toots yeah
they're they're they're listening to you
we're sitting there yeah
um but the military leaders of japan
decided you know what we're going to
[ __ ] war he's
they they took a couple of bows and they
said we're going to war so
yama uh yamamoto
he didn't want to do this but he had no
choice um so he had to go to the war and
he was given the unfortunate task
of uh of attacking pearl harbor and um
he said that uh he knew
even though the damage i mean they
destroyed pearl i mean they they got a
decisive victory in pearl harbor they
sunk battleships they killed two
thousand
uh us troops and civilians um yeah but
they did wake up the boys
the thing is but they walk with the boys
but he said later on a couple months
later that it was a big mistake because
then in the battle of
uh midway which he was also present at
make no mistake the japanese got [ __ ]
field goal kicked
yeah and then and then um hiroshima and
nagasaki which
yeah which yeah yeah which historians
say
wasn't necessary a lot of historians
claim it wasn't necessary because they
felt like
the war was already won japan was going
to capitulate but that we did it
in order to scare stalin because we knew
that the cold war was strong
probably true no that's an atrocious uh
thing that happened all around that we
did too but on the flip side you say hey
at least
the world got to see how bad it can be
and hopefully never happens again so
like yeah it's like one of those things
it's like that same
private ryan thing a horrible thing
happened but
it's for a bigger cause you know it's
like you can't make omelets without
breaking eggs
maybe that's the silver lining of it i'm
not claiming that is yeah because a lot
of people suffered and it was very
horrible
yeah people but at least suffering in
japan to this day so it's brutal yeah
with radiation all that but you can say
at least
maybe that's the silver lining that's
what it is
but yeah maybe we probably didn't need
to do it but you know war is war
and uh it's brutal brutal all around and
you did attack us first
yeah so you did do what you did
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was
about this is just a stock thing that
we're taping on to every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it
and go to where patreon.com get really
[Music]
wild